[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Manuel Bompard
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
économiques madame la présidente madame
la ministre chers
collègues en dépit de vos multiples
tentatives de diversion le pouvoir
d'achat demeure la principale
préoccupation de nos
compatriotes qui peut dire ici les yeux
dans les yeux qu'il ne rencontrre pas
chaque jour des Français en colère face
à la hausse des prix au supermarché ou à
la station service comment pourrait-il
en être autrement alors que l'inflation
s'est envolée depuis fin 2021
pour atteindre 6,2 % en octobre
2022 un tel niveau d'inflation n'avait
pas été observé depuis les années 1980
en France l'explosion est encore plus
flagrante lorsque l'on regarde dans le
détail sur 1 an plus 23 % pour les
pommes de terre plus 28 % sur les purées
de pommes de terre plus 26 % pour les
plats cuisinés à base de pâte plus 23 %
sur le sucre la liste est longue et la
situation est insupportable pour nos
concitoyens car si ces chiffres peuvent
paraître abstraits ils traduisent un
état de maltraitance sociale généralisé
nos concitoyens ne parviennent plus à se
nourrir à se loger à se chauffer ou à se
déplacer ils sont obligés de se priver
et sacrifie des petits bonheurs de la
vie quotidienne comme la teste la baisse
de la consommation des ménages depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois selon l'Ifop
près d'un Français sur tris déclare
devoir sauter un repas par manque
d'argent et 43 % affirment avoir déjà
renoncé pour cette raison à acheter des
produits
alimentaires les conséquences sont très
concrètes plus de 2,4 millions de
personnes ont eu recours aux banques
alimentairire en 2022 soit trois fois
plus qu'en 2011 et 400000 personnes de
plus qu'en
2020 or de nombreux organismes qui ne
sont pas des officines de la France
insoumise ont pointé le rôle majeur qui
a joué la progression des marges des
entreprises dans cette hausse
vertigineuse des prix selon le Fond
monétaire internationale l'augmentation
des profits a été la première cause de
l'inflation en 2022 et sur le premier
semestre de l'année
2023 il y a quelques mois Benoît ceré
président de l'Autorité de la
concurrence pense affirmer je cite que
les 2/ de l'inflation sont du à une
augmentation des prix au-delà des
hausses de coût supporté par les
entreprises regardons la réalité en face
alors que les prix des produits
alimentaires ont augmenté de plus de 20
% en 2 ans les marges de l'industrie
agroalimentaire ont bondi de 70 % dans
la même période de même alors que le
prix du carburant tourne depuis
plusieurs mois autour de 2 € litre les
marches des raffineurs ont été multiplié
par 5 entre le printemps et l'automne de
l'année 2023 pour résumer pendant que de
plus en plus de Français se serent la
ceinture une petite minorité sur ce gave
sur le dos du plus grand nombre comment
peut-on continuer à
l'accepter pourtant face à cette urgence
sociale et cette injustice profonde le
gouvernement multiplie les déclarations
d'un intention et les opérations de
communication sans effet Bruno Le Maire
suggère Bruno Le Maire demande Bruno Le
Maire espère Bruno Le Maire souhaite
Bruno Le Maire supplie Bruno Le Maire
écrit Bruno Le Maire publie mais Bruno
Le Maire refuse de faire ce que l'on
attend de lui agir enfin par la loi
contre les abus agir pour le plus grand
nombre et non pas pour protéger les
intérêts d'une petite minorité enfin
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et rendre leur vie moins
difficile c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons avec cette proposition de loi
de faire enfin aujourd'hui ce que le
gouvernement refuse de faire depuis des
mois avec mes collègues de la France
àoumise nous vous proposons donc quatre
mesures concrètes pour faire baisser
immédiatement le prix des produits
alimentaires et du carburant tout en
proté
les agriculteurs également victime de la
cupidité de quelques acteurs
économiques la première de ces mesures
vise à fixer des prix planchers pour les
produits agricoles pour chaque filière
les négociations seraient placées sous
l'égide du médiateur des relations
commerciales agricoles et en cas d'échec
des négociations ces prix seraient
déterminé par les ministres compétents à
partir des indicateurs de coût de
production et de l'État des lieux des
négociations établis par ce même
rapporteur la deuxième mesure permet
d'encadrer les marges des industries
agroalimentaires et de la grande
distribution au vu de la situation
actuelle il s'agit d'une part
d'instaurer pour l'année 2024 des
coefficients multiplicateurs maximum
afin que les marges réalisées ne
puissent pas être supérieur au marges
moyennes réalisé sur les 10 dernières
années d'autre part afin de pouvoir
réagir immédiatement en cas de nouvelle
crise inflationniste il s'agit de
déclencher automatiquement un tel
dispositif lorsque la variation des
indices de prix fait apparaître
l'existence de Marg abusives dans la
transformation ou dans la
distribution bien sûr et j'anticipe sans
doute par la même des interventions qui
seront faites dans la discussion ces
dispositifs ne concneraient pas nos
petites et moyenes entreprises ou nos
épiceries pour se concentrer
exclusivement sur les géants de
l'agroalimentaire et de la grande
distribution qui sont les véritables
profiteurs de
crise la troisième mesure porte
spécifiquement sur le prix de l'essence
comme vous le savez c'est un sujet de
préoccupation extrêmement sensible pour
nos concitoyens il s'agit d'instaurer
ici également un coefficient
multiplicateur pour éviter que la marge
brute de raffinage n'atteigne des
sommets sans commune mesure avec
l'évolution du cours du pétrole il est
temps enfin de puiser dans les profits
de Total et des géants du pétrole pour
agir pour faire en sorte que les
difficultés des Français soient moins
importantes qu'aujourd'hui la 4ème
mesure enfin vise à renforcer les
pouvoirs de l'Observatoire de formation
des prix et des marges alimentaires
celui-ci doit pouvoir disposer de
véritbles moyens d'enquête et de
sanction pour permettre une véritable
transparence sur la formation des prix
et sur les marges réalisées par les
différents acteurs de la chaîne
alimentaire preuve que nous sommes
ouverts à la discussion nous nous
appuierons ici sur l'article 2 de la
proposition de loi qui est adopté en
commission qui est issue d' d'un
amendement du groupe les républicains
certains d'entre vous m'objecteront
peut-être que l'inflation semble
ralentir depuis quelques semaines je
rappelle à ce sujet qu'un ralentissement
de l'inflation ne signifie pas une
baisse des prix les prix vont continuer
à augmenter ils ne feront qu'augmenter
moins rapidement de plus depuis l'été
2022 le ministre de l'Économie et des
Finances n'a eu cesse de proclamer que
ça y est nous avons atteint le pic de
l'inflation nous étions censés l'avoir
atteint en juin 2022 en juillet 2022 en
août 2022 en janvier 2023 en février
2023 en mars 2023 de pic en pic nous
avons plutôt parcouru une chaîne de
l'inflation quant àé une réelle descente
on nous pardonnera donc d'être
circonscrit sur les prévisions de le
maire c'est pourquoi outre notre c'est
pourquoi notre proposition comprend
outre des mesures d'effet immédiat des
mécanismes pérennes qui permettront à
l'avenir de répondre immédiatement et de
manière efficace aux éventuelles
poussées inflationnistes comme vous le
voyez chers collègues cette proposition
de loi se veut concrète et utile je vous
invite donc à l'examiner pour ce qu'elle
est indépendamment de nos étiquettes
politiques respective je remercie
d'ailleurs les députés qui dans le cadre
des des travaux en commission ont
proposé des des amendements pour
améliorer ce texte car il s'agit tout
simplement aujourd'hui d'apporter une
réponse au problème de la vie chère et
de mettre un terme à une situation
d'injustice
insupportable chers collègues le 24
septembre dernier le président de la
République s'engagé à mettre en place je
cite un accord sur la modération des
marges dans tout le secteur alimentaire
le lendemain la premierère ministre
convoquer les acteurs de la filière du
carburant pour je cite faire la
transparence sur leur marge et demander
leur réduction 2 jours plus tard le 27
septembre le ministre de l'Économie
affirmé qu'il vaillerit à ce que les
marges réalisées dans l'alimentaire
soient raisonnables il ajouté je cite
c'est le rôle de l'État de garantir
qu'il n'y a pas de profit qui soit
excessif et que l'argent soit rendu au
consommateurs mais depuis cette date
rien de concret n'a été fait quatre
associations de consommateurs l'ont
d'ailleurs rappelé dans un courrier
adressé hier au président de la
République
lui demande ce qu'il attend pour agir et
l'exhorte à faire la lumière sur la
construction des prix et à mettre fin au
plus vite aux marges excessive
aujourd'hui nous avons enfin l'occasion
de passer des paroles aux actes nous
avons une manière simple de soulager les
difficultés des Français et de leur
apporter un peu de répis dans une
situation si difficile c'est donc chers
collègues en ayant en tête cette
responsabilité que je vous propose que
nous examinions cette proposition de loi
je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du
[Applaudissements]
tourisme
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
députés nous avons dans cette hémicycle
des divergences fondamentales sur
lesquelles nous ne pourrons jamais être
d'accord cela ne devrait pas vous
surprendre avec cette proposition de loi
mais je crois que ça ne doit aucunement
empêcher le débat lorsqu'il est courtois
respectueux et permet de confronter des
faits des théories des projets pour
notre pays votre de loi prétend donc
proposer une solution de lutte contre
l'inflation et ce en encadrant les
marges de l'industrie agroalimentaires
des raffineurs et des
distributeurs ce large chantier soulève
plusieurs questions auxquelles vous vous
en doutter en tant que ministre de la
consommation je ne saurais être
insensible d'abord ce texte pose la
question de la préservation du pouvoir
d'achat des Français face à une
inflation mondiale je rappellerai ici
que la politique du gouvernement a
permis d'absorber une bonne partie du
choc inflationniste comme l'a rappelé
Linc pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière dans son édition 2023 de son
ouvrage France portrait social les
mesures sociales et fiscales prises par
ce gouvernement soutenu par cette
majorité ont selon l'INC conduit à un
gain moyen de 190 € par an et par
personne surtout ces gains calculés par
l'INC ne tiennent pas compte des mesures
de limitation des prix comme la remise à
la pompe les boucliers tarifaires sur
l'énergie qui ont eu un effet direct sur
les dépenses de consommation des
Français depuis 2 ans je rappelle que
les boucliers
tarifaires depuis 2 ans les boucliers
tarifaires ont permis de faire baisser
de 150 à 200 € la facture mensuelle de
chaque foyer soit entre 1800 et 2400 €
par an je ne suis pas ici en train de me
satisfaire mesdames Messieurs les les
députés ne vous y trompez pas je ne
méconnais aucunement les difficultés
persistantes de nombreux Français à se
loger à se nourrir obligé de se priver
en sautant pour certains d'entre eux un
repas ou en sollicitant une aide
alimentaire je sais que c'est difficile
je sais que c'est long je suis
simplement en train de dire que nous
sommes à la tâche ce texte de loi
soulève la question de la méthode et en
l'occurrence question passionnante la
question du rôle de l'État en matière
d'intervention dans l'économie nous
croyons que si l'État doit intervenir et
il l'a fait je le rappelle à chacune des
crise passée cette intervention doit
être temporaire et surtout
avisé ce que vous avez présenté avec
votre texte originel ça n'est ni une
mesure temporaire ni une mesure
avisée vérifier contrôler ce n'est pas
fixé unilatéralement aveuglément les
niveaux de marge les prix comme ça a été
le cas à Cuba en Union soviétique avec
les succès que nous leur
connaissons vous proposiez vous
proposiez initialement de fixer à
174 le coefficient
multiplicateur au-delà duquel un
industriel de l'agroalimentaire ne
pouvait vendre son produit par rapport à
son prix
[Musique]
d'achat madame la ministre a la parole
vous proposiez initialement de fixer à
1,74 le coefficient multiplicateur
au-delà duquel un industriel de
l'agroalimentaire ne peut vendre son
produit par rapport à son prix d'achat à
13 pour les activités de raffinage à 12
pour les marges de la grande
distribution pour qui pourquoi avec vous
ça n'est pas la main invisible du marché
c'est le doigt mouillé légiférer avec
autant de légèreté interroge les
responsables politiques que nous sommes
vous proposez des interdiction sur la
base des indicateurs français auxquels
des entreprises étrangères et vous le
savez pourrai très facilement
s'affranchir avez-vous largement
consulté avez-vous non seulement juste
fait une étude d'impact pour montrer que
ça ne se traduira pas par plus
d'importations par exemple vous
êtes-vous un seul instant posé la
question des effets délétaires de cette
proposition sans compter une part
d'absurdité bureaucratique qu'elle
engendre avez-vous prévu un système de
contrôle de sanction qui pourrait être
approprié vérifier que vos si vos
mesures étaient financées comment ça se
passe pour les TPE nos plus petits
acteurs économiques les PME les petites
entreprises ce sont les mêmes règles que
pour les
multinationales en fait je juste pouvoir
m'exprimer
juste je suis à mon maximum madame la
ministre en même temps là je alors je
vais monter le
volume puisque nous sommes entrés dans
une
période c'est dommage de pas pouvoir
échanger moi je vous écoute on n pas
d'accord mais on
s'écoute puisque nous sommes entrés dans
une période où il y aura nécessairement
une forte volatilité des cours des
matières premières agricoles et vous le
savez comment gérer les années où il y
aura des pertes qui ne pourront pas être
compensé par plus de résultats vous
êtes-vous un seul instant poser la
question de la compatibilité de vos
mesures pérennes avec la constitution ou
avec le cadre européen contrairement à
ce qu'a pu faire légalement le
gouvernement lorsqu'il est intervenu
ponctuellement en période de crise sur
le prix des geles hydroalcooliques par
exemple oui c'est d'intervenir oui et
nous l'avons fait mais pas n'importe
comment et pas pour n'importe quoi votre
méthode sans aucune étude d'impact sans
concertation sans discernement c'est la
mort de nos éleveurs de PME dont les
grand groupe se détourneraiit et vous le
savez au profit de produits moins chers
de moins bonne qualité on
s'approvisionnant à l'étranger où notre
législation ne pourra pas s'appliquer on
ne peut pas s'attaquer aux grandes mul
national sans s'assurer qu'une
restriction ou une interdiction ne
conduira pas à des effets pires que le
mal qu'on souhaite combattre la France
n'est toujours pas une île elle est
insérée dans un tissu économique mondial
qui est aujourd'hui globalement ouvert
qu'on le veille ou non un tissu
perméable aux décisions prises par un
gouvernement qui conduit souvent à des
arbitrages de la part d'opérateurs
privés et les décisions que nous prenons
oui elles influencent les décisions des
investisseurs des dirigeants des groupes
internationaux dont la France ne
représente même si c'est dur à entendre
qu'un marché parmi tant d'autres le
gouvernement mène une politique
cohérente depuis des années en faveur de
l'attractivité qui se traduit
effectivement par un mouvement de
réindustrialisation et oui avec comme
objectif la souveraineté industrielle du
pays mais aussi la souveraineté
alimentaire pour la 4e année consécutive
je sais que vous n'aimez pas ces
chiffres pour la 4
année consécutive la France demeure le
pays le plus attractif d'Europe avec
1259 projets d'investissement recensés
dans l'Hexagone en 2022 et derrière même
si ça ne vous plaît pas ce sont des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois qui sont
créés combien serait détruit avec ces
mesures que vous porte aujourd'hui une
telle politique ne se fait pas contre
les acteurs économiques ce que surtout
doit combattre l'état ce sont les marges
dites indu ce sont les marges qui
résultent d'une structure
oligopolistique
ou monopolistique d'un marché ce sont
des marges abusives qui résultent d'une
structure de marché qui n'est pas
suffisamment ouverte pour que le jeu
d'une concurrence libre et non faussée
fixe le juste prix et c'est en agissant
sur ces paramètres en s'assurant que la
concurrence joue pleinement son rôle
qu'on combat les marges abusives parce
il ne peut pas y avoir de marge abusive
si il y a de la concurrence nous ne
serons pas d'accord mais j'ai quand même
à cœur de terminer en vous rappelant que
le rapporteur général de l'Autorité de
la Concurrence a d'ailleurs annoncé
lundi enquêé dans le secteur de la
production de la distribution de
produits de grande consommation
alimentaire mais aussi non alimentaire
pour des pratiques anticoncurrentielles
susceptibles d'avoir été mises en œuvre
s'il y a eu des abus mesdames Messieurs
les parlementaires ils seront
sanctionnés et vous connaissez le niveau
de sanction élevé auquel s'exposent les
entreprises qui ne jouent pas le jeu
normal de la concurrence j'ajoute que
votre proposition de loi qui concerne
l'avenir qui devrait nous projeter sur
les prochaines années ne permet en
l'occurrence pas de traiter ces marges
excessives historiques avez-vous dit que
vous dénoncez ce texte est un prétexte
pour proposer un remède dangereux à un
mal les marges excessives que nous
dénonçons également vous le constatez
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs les députés
nous avons nous aurons matière à
débattre projet contre projet fait
contre fait ayons je l'espère un débat
qui soit à la hauteur pour débattre non
pas de l'objectif commun qui est je
crois partager permettre au français de
se nourrir mais véritablement de la
bonne méthode pour y parvenir je vous
remercie merci madame la
ministre nous en venons à la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Aurélie
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
n madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues la lutte
contre l'inflation voyez-vous c'est un
peu l'arlaisienne dans cet hémicycle 2
ans d'annonce 2 ans de promesses 2 ans
de prière aux multinationales 2 ans de
Haos sans discontinuer des prix aliment
et ça continue encore et encore et nos
concitoyens n'en peuvent plus il y a
plusieurs façons de répondre en vérité à
l'inflation et de lutter contre mais
vous n'en utilisez aucune alors nous on
vous en propose une la plus efficace
s'attaquer
ou en tout cas tempérer les marches des
grands groupes madame la ministre je
dois vous dire je vous ai bien entendu
je crois bien que vous n'utilisez pas la
bonne version du texte je suis désolé de
vous le dire
et
oui par exemple dans le texte il y a
bien des moyens de contrôle donc
manifestement vous n'z pas la bonne
fiche pour vous démontrer le sens de la
proposition de loi que nous allons
défendre je vais m'appuyer sur le
rapport de la Fondation pour la Nature
et l'Homme publié mardi et je vous
propose de vous imaginer au supermarché
vous allez préparer un gâteau une crêpe
et vous allez acheter une brique de lait
cette brique de lait vous l'achetez 4 3
centimes hors taxe il y a 20 ans c'était
55 centimes vous l'achetez donc vous
aurez compté avec moi 28 centimes plus
cher qu'il y a 20 ans alors là vous
dites comment ça se fait pe-être qui va
empocher qui a empocher ces 28 centimes
de plus qui en profite bref alors
peut-être que c'est l'éleveur puisque le
lait vient de ses vaches et ben pas du
tout dans les 93 centimes de votre
brique de lait l'éleveur n'en empoche
que 24 centimes 1 centime de moins qu'il
y a 20 ans cet éleveur comme vous le
savez il bosse 58 heur par semaine il se
même il ne se paye même pas en moyenne
un SMIC horaire donc c'est pas lui qui
en profite bien au contraire alors qui
l'éleveur vous le savez ils vend son
lait de vache à une multinationale comme
c'est le plus souvent le cas par exemple
par exemple l'ctalis ça pourrait être
Danon savencia comme ce sont des grosses
entreprises ah oui peut-être une petite
parenthèse la libre concurrence la
concurrence libre et non faussé ça
n'existe pas dans les filières
agroalimentaires il y a des oligopoles
madame la ministre si vous voulez je
fais des cours là-dessus en économie il
y a pas de problème donc il y a pas
d'autrre option dans la région pour cet
éleveur laitier que et bien de livrer
par exemple à Lactalis qui fait quand
même un tiers de la collecte laitière
française et donc il va s'imposer à lui
en lui vendant son lait encore moins
cher et ça marche par contre l'ctalis
qui est une grosse multinationale c'est
la première multinationale du monde de
produits laitiers comme comm vous le
savez et bien elle va vendre plus cher
sa bruque de lait bien plus cher par
exemple à Carrefour Carrefour qui
lui-même et bien va va faire payer
encore plus cher les consommateurs parce
que lui aussi il est en situation de ce
qu'on appelle un oligopole donc en 20
ans votre brique de lait au consommateur
elle vous coûte 28 centimes de plus
l'éleveur a perdu 1 centime en 20 ans
donc évidemment vous dites où sont passé
mais 29 centimes si vous avez bien
compté avec moi celle qui transforme où
ça où c'est pass et bien dans les poches
des multinationales qui transformment le
lait comme Lactalis Lactalis en 20 ans
14 centimes de plus et Carrefour en 20
ans 15 centimes de plus sur la brique de
lait voilà où sont passés vos 29
centimes dans les poches des
multinationales des actionnaires et de
leurs grands patrons ainsi Carrefour a
augmenté ses bénéfices de 26 % en un an
alors là vous dites pourquoi faire
peut-être les salariés peut-être les
investissements non non non augmenter
les dividendes de ses actionnaires de 8
% en 1 an augmenter aussi le revenu de
son PTG Alexandre bonpard 9 millions
d'euros annuels soit 540 fois le SMIC
tout en payant la plupart de ses
salariés notamment les caissier au SMIC
et en envirant 1000 cette année quant à
laactalis alors l'actalis on connaît pas
tout mais en fait c'est les marques
Lactel président calban Bridel et cetera
son patron milliardaire la fortune de
France Emmanuel beignier voit sa fortune
exploser grâce et je reprends les mots
de notre estimé collègue Stéphane traver
quand il était ministre de l'Agriculture
grâce à une multinationale au-dessus des
lois comme vous le voyez on est loin de
la concurrence libre et non faussé
madame la
ministre heureusement il y a certains de
vos collègues qui s'en rendent compte
avant vous heureusement le ministre de
l'Économie Bruno le ma s'est rendu
compte de tout ça il y a 6 mois il est
arrivé il a dit on va pas laisser les
Industri Industri les gros industriels
faire des marges indu là le président
Macron a menacé d'envoyer des
contrôleurs pour vérifier si les profils
nétaient pas
excessif alors ça a pas beaucoup
trembler côté Lactalis et Carrefour
autant vous le dire d'ailleurs ils
attendent toujours les contrôleur quant
à leurs patrons et grands actionnaires
ils sont toujours à la fête leur grande
richesse augmentent au même rythme que
les prix du lait des pâtes du sucre des
légumes des patates les patates plus 25
% en un an leur grande richesse augmente
donc au fur à mesure de la fin dans ce
pays donc et je finirai là-dessus quand
nos concitoyens iront acheter leur BRI
de lait qui devront encore la payer plus
cher qu'ils galéreront à finir le mois
parce qu'il payent tout plus cher il
faut qu'il sache qui en est responsable
et le seul et l'unique responsable c'est
le président Macron et son gouvernement
qui n'ont rien fait absolument rien fait
pour empêcher les prix et les profits
des plus riches senver vous parlez
madame la ministre d'un remède dangereux
mais c'est vous qui êtes dangereux vous
parlez de projets contre projet mais
vous n'avez aucun aucun projet nous nous
voulons que ces citoyens et ses
consommateurs sachent que le 30 novembre
2023 dans cet hémicycle une loi a été
proposée pour empêcher que les prix et
les profits ne s'envolent qu'une loi a
été proposée pour que les consommateurs
et les agriculteurs cessent d'être pris
à la gorge par les multinationales et
leurs profits ils sauront ils saont quel
député a vootter pour la loi en faveur
des 68 millions de consommateurs et des
centaines de milliers d'agriculteurs et
à l'inverse quel député a voté pour les
multinationales et leurs profit chers
collègues c'est maintenant l'heure du
choix merci madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur
Grégoire de fournaz pour le groupe
rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues notre pays fait face à une
inflation alimentaire sans précédent
depuis la guerre en Ukraine les prix de
l'alimentation ont en effet augmenté de
25 % écrasant les ménages qui doivent de
surcroix faire face à l'explosion du
coût de l'énergie et notamment du
carburant cette inflation alimentaire a
des conséquences dramatiques baisse des
achats entaire un français sur 6 déclare
ne pas manger à sa fin un sur 3 saute
même des repas et malgré cette explosion
des prix de l'alimentation les
agriculteurs français continuent de
produire en dessous de leur coût de
revien le tiers d'entre eux vivent avec
moins de 500 € par mois les
exploitations décapitalisent les
productions s'effondrent laissant place
à des importations en constante
augmentation ce résultat catastrophique
c'est le vôtre les trois lois etgalim
qui ont imposé de nouvelles contraintes
aux agriculteurs n'ont permis de de
couvrir que très partiellement
l'augmentation de leur charg et ils ne
vivent toujours pas de leur métier la
seule et réelle efficacité des LO Galim
aura été d'acc d'accélérer pardon
l'inflation alimentaire dans des
proportions considérables car vous avez
accepté le principe intrinsèquement
inflationniste de l'augmentation du prix
au consommateur pour mieux rémunérer le
producteur vous êtes en effet passer à
côté de l'éléphant au milieu du couloir
que sont les marges abusives des
industriels et de la grande distribution
qui tu les agricultures et asphyie les
consommateurs ce qu'a toujours dénoncé
le rassemblement national et ceux contre
V et Maré en refusant de remettre en
question ces marges abusives vous avez
même renvoyé dos à dos les agriculteurs
et les consommateurs dans cette équation
infernale où il n'y aurait pas d'autre
choix que d'aider l'un en sacrifiant
l'autre non seulement vous n'avez pas
voulu limiter ces marges abusives mais
vous les avez même augmenté en créant le
seuil de revente à perte plus 10 % idée
bien naïve qui a coûté 600 millions
d'euros aux consommateurs et qui n'a
jamais russelé au producteurs le
rapporteur avait proposé sa suppression
dans son texte initial mais de façon
surprenante et à renoncé en séance nous
avons déposé un amendement pour que nous
puissions enfin supprimer ce SRP +1
quand les Français n'arrive plus à se
nourrir et que notre agriculture
continue de disparaître l'inaction du
gouvernement et de cette majorité est
profondément coupable il n'est plus
temps d'attendre d'hypothétiques points
d'étapes de bilan de concertation de
table ronde ou d'un fumeux pacte de
modération des marges qui ne sont pour
vous qu'une manière de gagner du temps
et de masquer votre inaction face à cet
enjeu et cette urgence il convient de
faire preuve de pragmatisme et que
chacun remette en question ses
certitudes j'ai bien entendu le
président de la commission nous
justifier son refus de principes de ce
texte en raison de sa fidélité à ses à
ses convictions prétendument libérales
s'il est toujours un peu surprenant
d'entendre un macroniste nous parler de
convergence de cohérence idéologique je
voudrais lui dire que nous ne sommes
plus en 1980 que le mur de Berlin est
tombé que bregneev et Ran sont morts et
qu'en 2023 la menace n'est plus le Parti
communiste qui plafonne à 2 % mais
plutôt la prédation de la finance et des
multinationales qui ruinent l'économie
française ne tombez
pas ne tombez pas dans cette facilité
chers collègues de la majorité de
dénoncer une prétendue convergence
idéologique entre le rassemblement
national et la France insoumise qui
n'existe et vous le savez que dans vos
éléments de langage
face à l'immobilisme et l'impuissance du
gouvernement à luttter contre
l'inflation et la rue des agriculteurs
oui il existe des députés de tout bord y
compris quelques-uns dans la majorité
qui prennent leur responsabilités et qui
veulent trouver des solutions qui n'est
pas contre les marge délirante des
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire en
augmentation de 70 % en l'un an et demi
qui n'est pas scandalisé de voir dans
les rayons de la grande distribution des
légumes vendus à des prix 10 fois
supérieurs de ce payer au producteurs
face à ce scandale les Français nous
demandent d'agir nous nous réjouissons
que le rapporteur a inclus dans son
texte un certain nombre de nos
propositions d'amélioration comme la
différenciation madame la ministre des
grandes multinationales et des petites
entreprises vous l'avez compris nous
accompagnerons cette proposition de
loi merci monsieur le député la parole
est à Madame anneel babo pour le groupe
démocrate modemme et
indépendant
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui une
proposition de loi de nos collègues de
la France insoumise qui pose une vraie
question de fond en y apportant une
réponse totalement
démagogique car votre proposition
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur est
purement inopérante c'est bien ce qui
est ressorti des auditions et c'est ce
qui a été partagé durant les débats avec
les collègues de la commission des
affaires économiques je m'explique cette
proposition intervient dans un contexte
inflationniste continue depuis plus de 2
ans déclenché au moment de la reprise
postcovid de l'économie mondiale et
alimenté depuis par les différentes
crises internationales et notamment
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie il
me semble important de rappeler que les
sanctions internationales notamment
contre le gaz et le pétrole russe ont
ainsi conduit à une flambée des coûts de
production et de transport dans
l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur
la guerre sur le sol ukrainien a
également agité les marchés des matières
premières agricooles et notamment du blé
conduisant des augmentations irrationnel
de leur prix alors que le risque de
pénurie était selon les spécialistes
purement
virtuel ceci étant l'inflation quant à
elle est devenue bien réelle dans le
quotidien des Français notamment sur les
produits alimentaires où il a où elle a
atteint 18 % depuis
janvier nous comprenons donc totalement
les motifs qui vous ont conduit à
déposer ce texte mais encore une fois
nous ne partageons pas les solutions
tout d'abord vous constaterez comme moi
chers collègues que l'inflation
alimentaire reflu passant de 15 % sur un
an en juin à 7,7 % en octobre l'INC
annonce ce matin une inflation générale
de 3,4 % sur 1 an en novembre confirmant
une baisse
tendantielle concernant les marges
industrielles les auditions que monsieur
le rapporteur a mené ont permis de
mettre en évidence le décalage entre la
variation des prix des matières
premières et la variation des prix en
rayon ainsi au début de l'épisode
inflationniste les marches sont
contractées sous l'effet de
l'augmentation du prix des intrants
c'est ensuite face à la persistance de
l'inflation que les industriels ont
décidé de rattraper les pertes qu'ils
ont subis en augmentant les prix et leur
marges qui on augmenté de 18 % au
premier trimestre
2023 mes chers collègues de la France
insoumise vous qui souhaitez instaurer
un contrôle des marges de manière
aveugle
savez-vous seulement qui est responsable
de cette augmentation pour échanger
régulièrement avec les PME ce ne sont
certainement pas elles elles ont pris de
plein fouet la hausse des coûts de
l'énergie et ont voulu limiter la hausse
de leur prix afin de conserver leur
courant d'affaires avec leurs clients et
les consommateurs finaux vous nous
proposez un dispositif de contrôle des
marges sans même avoir les différences
établies entre les tailles d'entrepris
et les différentes catégories de
produits c'est pourquoi le groupe
démocrate a soutenu la proposition du
collègue div a mandaté l'Observatoire de
la formation des prix et des marges pour
qu'il effectue des contrôles
réguliers nous vous proposons également
en cohérence avec les autres groupes de
la majorité de donner des moyens
supplémentaires à l'observatoire pour
mener des enquêtes en cas de soupçon de
marge
abusive la question que pose votre
proposition monsieur rapporteur est
celle du partage de la valeur tout au
long de la chaîne
agroalimentaire sur ce point nous
pouvons noter que les prix des produits
agricoles ont certes augmenté de 23 % en
202 2 mais poussé par une hausse de leur
coût de production et des cours
internationaux avec la baisse des prix
qui viendra nous devrons nous assurer
qu'elle ne se fasse pas sur le dos des
agriculteurs afin qu'il soit payé au
juste prix c'est pour cette raison que
nous sommes également opposé à la
suppression du SRP +1 avant qu'une
évaluation complète du dispositif ne
soit réalisée nos agriculteurs doivent
relever de nombreux défis dont le
premier le renouvellement des
générations par l'attrait du métier cela
passe nécessairement par le
revenu cet enjeu du partage de la valeur
doit être traité avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés c'est pourquoi nous ne
croyons pas au groupe démocrate que
cette question se résoudra de manière
verticale par une économie
semi-administrée je vous remercie merci
madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Dominique potier pour le groupe
socialiste et
apparenté madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
redire que nous partageons tous
l'émotion qui éta exprimé par le
rapporteur qui a été repris par
différents orateurs sur cette situation
absolument insupportable qui fait que
des millions de Français aujourd'hui
doivent arbitrer entre l'alimentation le
soin le logement c'est une honte il faut
le dire pour notre pays c'est une honte
profonde et à ce moment-là nous devons
rendre hommage à minima avant de
développer nos idées sur sur la
proposition de loi au courage de ces
Français qui font face à cette pauvreté
et au courage de tous ceux qui s'engage
à leur côté je pense aux associations
caritatives aujourd'hui sur le front et
en grande difficulté pour faire face à
une un agroissement de la demande mais
cette compassion pour ce courage et pour
la charité ne doit en aucun cas nous
distraire de notre exigence absolu de
justice cet effort de justice il doit
porter non seulement sur sur les
allocations de l'État providence et le
soutien de l'État providence mais il
doit porter sur les mécanismes de
l'économie afin que sous une forme de
prévention nous puissions résoudre les
causes profondes qui amènent à cette
inflation à cette injustice majeur ça
été un effort qui a été engagé dès 2016
ce son les lois sapin 2 en matière de
régulation des prix agricoles et
alimentaires c'estgalim 1 en 2018 et
Galim 2 la loi descroosail dit
descroosaill et puis plus récemment
initiative de Bruno Le Maire je ne
commenterai pas sur l'avancement de 15
jours des négociations commercialesou de
un mois de quelques jours la 6e
proposition signée par Manuel bonpard au
autour du groupe avec le groupe la
France insoumise dans cette niche est
stimulante sur le plan intellectuelle et
moi je refuse que dans une posture
idéologique nous l'écartions d'emblé le
groupe socialiste la regarde avec
bienveillance et sprête à l'amender en
rappelant d'abord les principes qu'
l'anime nos principes sont ceux du fait
que le pouvoir d'achat des Français ne
veut pas se construire au détriment de
notre appareil productif sinon nous
laissons cours à toutes les opérations
des chinoiseries qui aujourd'hui
envahissent notre pays et c'est le sens
par exemple de la démarche du groupe
socialiste qui a porté plainte à l'OCDE
contre le groupe Chine pour dire que le
pouvoir d'achat des Français ne pouvait
pas se faire par la porte ouverte à
n'importe quel dumping social
environnemental et fiscal de par le
monde c'est également de rappeler que en
même temps ce pouvoir d'achat ne peut
pas être l'otage d'oligopole dans
l'agroalimentaire ou dans l'énergie qui
par des profits indu viennent
ponctionner le pouvoir de vivre de nos
concitoyens nos principes sont également
ceux de la transparence nous savons très
bien qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la
vérité des prix de la construction des
prix parce que les transferts de coût au
sein des multinationales l'optimisation
fiscale majeure qui est celle de la
grande distribution par la dissociation
du parc immobilier depuis l'appareil de
vente nous distrait de la vérité des
bénéfices qui sont faites par cette
grande distribution nous savons par
ailleurs que nous n'avons pas de
transparence sur le fait que certains
grands industriels de l'agroalimentaire
à l'échelle internationale ont un
quasiment monopole sur les prix qu'ils
fixent au consommateurs à la grande
distribution au consommateurs parce
qu'ils ont par l'imaginaire publicitaire
qu'ils ont créé créer une situation de
dépendance de servitude marchande qui
les rend tout puissant dans les
négociations comm
nous devons faire la transparence sur
ces trois éléments là et puis nous
devons développer des instruments de
régulation ce vous le comprendrez
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre qui sont ceux des socialistes
sont évidemment ceux de l'économie
sociale de marché de la régulation de la
social démocratie des instruments de la
sociale démocratie j'en citerai trois
que nous avons en permanence poursuivi
pendant toutes les discussions sur les
négociations commerciales c'est celle
d'indiicier les négociations annuelles
sur le cours des matières premières et
de vérifier que cette
indiciation cet indice puisse être
réellement mise en œuvre afin que soit
répercuté à la hausse mais également à
la baisse ce qui n'a pas été fait tous
les effets de marché le deuxième c'est
le commerce équitable qui est le modèle
non pas une niche mais la norme vers
laquelle nous devrions tendre
c'est-à-dire la capacité à rémunérer
justement d'un bout à l'autre de la
chaîne de production tous les
travailleurs de la terre enfin c'est
ceux des contrats tripartites
plurannuels qui nous permettent une
visibilité la construction d'un prix la
construction de projets territoriaux et
de filières qui répondent à l'attente
des consommateurs avec un juste prix
sous réserve que cette proposition de
loi soit considérée comme une
expérimentation pour tants de crise sous
réserve que la cible soit bien identifié
et qu'elle nous distrait des PME et des
TPE de nos territoires et qu'elle cible
vraiment les multinationales sous
réserve qu'elle intègre les dispositions
d'empowerment et et de contrat que nous
proposons à travers le contrat
tripartite et le commerce
nous soutiendrons l'élaboration de ce
projet de loi et nous en débattrons à
l'instant de façon positive et
volontaire merci merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Thierry
Benoît pour le groupe horizon et
apparenté madame la ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
économiques monsieur bonpard monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur donc vous ID vous avez
identifié un sujet qui comme j'ai pu
vous le dire en commission au nom du
groupe horizon me tient particulièrement
à cœur c'est celui de du partage de la
valeur du partage de la richesse créée
dans un pays agricole dans le pays le
plus agricole de l'Union européenne qui
est la France et depuis depuis de
nombreuses années je me suis intéressé
avec d'autres députés sur différents
bancs de de cet hémicycle sur cette
question et c'est ce qui nous a conduit
en 2019 à enquêter à créer une
commission d'enquête pour essayer
d'approfondir et de voir un petit peu où
est le mal et ce qu'on a observé
finalement c'est que le secteur de la
distribution qui génère les discussions
commerciales appelées élégamment
négociation commerciales est un cteur
compliqué c'est un écosystème qui a créé
ses règles qui précède le décideurs
politique qu'il soi français ou
européens et c'est sans doute pour ça
que le secteur de la grande distribution
a créé des centrales d'achat
international lui permettant ainsi de
délocaliser une partie des négociations
commerciales hors de France et ainsi
échapper au code du commerce français
s'il subsiste de réels problèmes et de
réelles difficultés dans le secteur des
négociations commerciales il concerne
les discussions qui sont régies entre
les centrales internationales et
quelques dizaines de multinationales
c'est surtout là que doit se se
concentrer notre attention je vous l'ai
dit en commission personnellement je
vous ai suivi j'ai même déposé des
amendements identiques à vous l'été
dernier lorsque nous avions travaillé
sur le fait de taxer les super profits
et les super dividendes parce que ce que
nous payons aujourd'hui en France et
dans l'Union européenne c'est le
gigantisme financier c'est ça que nous
payons et j'ai beau être centriste de
cœur et de conviction je suis convaincu
qu'en matière d'économie il faut autant
de liberté que possible et autant de
régulation que nécessaire et ce dont on
a besoin aujourd'hui dans ce secteur des
discussions commerciales c'est de plus
de transp arence dans les méthodes dans
la vérité des coûts dans la vérité des
des comment des marges les négociation
commerciale aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelle le triple net les remises les
ristournes les Rabet auxquels vous
ajoutz les pénalités de toutes sortes y
compris les pénalités dites logistiqu
qui représentent des centaines de
millions d'euros en France mais aussi
les services dont certains services
internationaux n de service que le nom
parce que certains sont virtuels et pour
tout vous dire Monsieur le rapporteur je
SAÉ je reconnais votre volontarisme je
pense qu'une proposition de loi ne va
pas suffire pour
endiguer toutes ces problématique il
manque aussi je pense dans votre projet
le niveau de discussion et de réflexion
européenne lorsqu'on avait travaillé
avec la commission d'enquête j'ai vite
compris que nous en France nous avions
créé un certain nombre d'outils pour
encadrer pour mieux maîtriser le cadre
des négociations commerciale nous avons
la Direction Générale de la Concurrence
nous avons créé en France l'Autorité de
la concurrence nous avons la Commission
d'examen des pratiques commerciales et
nous AV et nous avons enfin
l'Observatoire de la formation des prix
et des marges et je pense monsieur le
rapporteur que votre proposition de loi
va elle peut permettre aujourd'hui une
avancée c'est sur le rôle que nous
pouvons confier à l'Observatoire de la
formation des prix et des marges en
terme d'enquête en terme de recherche
des éléments qui permettent de
constituer les marges du secteur de la
grande distribution et de certaines
multinationales de l'agroalimentire qui
jusqu'à présent refuse purement et
simplement parfois de donner les
éléments qui permettent de faire ces
calculs et à travers les amendements que
nous allons discutter je pense qu'on
peut entre guillemets atterrir et faire
adopter un article qui permet à
l'Observatoire de la formation des prix
desmarches de travailler avec la
Direction Générale de la Concurrence et
avec agrimè
avec comme objectif nous pour nous
députés du plus grand pays agricole
français de l'Union européenne et bien
de préserver l'élevage parce que
actuellement les agriculteurs tournent
les panneaux d'agglomération de nos
communes parce qu'ils considère que nous
marchons sur la tête je prends un seul
exemple je suis le député d'une région
en Bretagne où o il y a encore pour
l'instant du lait qui est en déprise
totale parce que dans le même temps on
demande à réduire le cheptel laitier
donc moins de prairies et on demande à
labourer les prairies pour faire des
cultures donc on voit bien qu'il y a là
un problème qui est lié au revenus
agricool qui est le sujet que vous
pointez à travers le partage de la
valeur merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Sophie
talier poan pour le groupe écologiste
nupest
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
depuis 3 ans maintenant la France subit
une explosion de l'inflation qui grève
considérablement le pouvoir de vivre des
Françaises et des Français en cause de
fortes tension sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique liée à la baisse
structurelle des ressources en énergie
fossile en cause le changement que qui
multiplie les épisodes de sécheresse
affectant durablement les productions
agricoles en cause la guerre menée par
la Russie en Ukraine qui fait flamber
les prix de l'énergie et des matières
premières agricoles en cause aussi les
marges outranières des oligopoles de la
grande distribution et de
l'agroalimentaire alors vous répétez un
lassablement que l'inflation baisse mais
nous insistons pour dire que les prix de
l'alimentation ne cessent d'augmenter en
2 ans l'infl tion alimentaire a atteint
plus de 22 % c'est absolument
insupportable pour les Françaises et les
Français qui sont chaque mois à l'euro
près derrière la flambée des prix
alimentaires se cache un système
scandaleux et opaque de profits et de
Marg ce sont les multinationales de
l'agroalimentaire et de la distribution
qui font la loi sur les prix dans notre
pays chaque année ils se réunissent
discuteent s'embrouille un petit peu
mais réussissent finalement toujours à
se mettre d'accord pour contrôler à leur
profit le prix de l'alimentation ce sont
ces géants en costume cravate qui
décident chaque année du niveau de
profit qu'ils vont faire l'année
suivante sur le dos des agriculteurs et
des agricultrices et des Françaises et
des Français oui les prix augmentent et
pendant ce temps les industries
agroalimentaires accumulent des marges
Records qui ont presque doublé en un an
contribuant à maintenir des prix
beaucoup trop haut résultat plus de la
moitié des Françaises et des Français
dit se priver occasionnellement ou
régulièrement d'un repas les fils
s'allongent à l'aide alimentaire et les
restos du cœur ne peuvent plus faire
face à la croissance de la précarité et
de la pauvreté dans notre pays face à
cela que fait le gouvernement que fait
l'état d'Emmanuel Macron franchement
c'est risible d'abord Bruno Le Maire
niait l'existence des profiteurs de
l'inflation puis il nous a gratifié
d'une de ses fameuses demandes en
incitant les super marché à mettre en
place des paniers anti-inflation Bruno
demande mais ne contrôle pas ne cadre
pas et laisse surtout chaque enseigne
faire ce qu'elle veut l'État a aussi
avancé les dates de négociation
commerciales de 2024 waouh mais encore
une fois sans aucune garantie de
résultat pour faire baisser les prix
nous écologistes l'avions déjà dit voilà
c'est à cela que ressemble la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron pour lutter contre
l'inflation ce ne sont que des rustines
des mesures de circonstances quelques
chèqu il est vrai payé par les Français
eux-mêmes grâce à la TVA qu'il payent
chaque jour en achetant leurs baguettes
de pain vous ne proposez aucune mesure
structurelle vous ne proposez rien qui
permette de d'en finir avec ce problème
la pauvreté les difficultés à
s'alimenter des Français de plus en plus
nombreux cela ne vous intéresse pas par
contre alors il y a toujours quelqu'un
au gouvernement pour venir appauvrir les
chômeurs leur demander davantage de
choses de de de justification ça il y a
quelqu'un mais pour lutter contre
l'inflation et ben il y a personne à
l'inverse ici dans cette proposition de
loi nous ne sommes pas dans une aème
mesure conjoncturelle le texte que nous
étudions de la France insoumise
aujourd'hui porte une vision beaucoup
plus équilibrée juste et transformatrice
pour toute la chaîne de valeur
alimentaire nos collègues proposent le
retour de l'État protecteur pour
rémunurer plus justement celles et ceux
qui travaillent la terre et nous
nourrissent grâce à la mise en place
d'un prix plancher pour les
agricultrices et les agriculteurs ce
texte propose le retour d'un état
protecteur en encadrant les marches des
industries de l'agroalimentaire du
raffinage et de la grande distribution
pour le pouvoir de vivre de nos
concitoyens et de nos concitoyenne à
cela nous disons enfin nous disons bravo
il est temps de mettre fin aux profits
excessifs de ces géants qui se goinfent
sur le dos des Français et des
agriculteurs il est temps que l'État
protecteur revienne pour protéger les
gens c'est cela l'intérêt
général par ailleurs nous soutiendrons
deux amendements spécifiques pour
soutenir l'accès à l'alimentation
rappelons-le aujourd'hui la bio
rencontre des difficultés majeures et
souvent les
distributeurs font des marges encore
plus importantes sur l'agriculture sur
les produits biologiques ce qui fait que
cela éloigne encore
davantage les plus précaires les classes
moyennes de l'accès à une alimentation
saine et de qualité donc oui nous
voterons pour ce texte en y ajoutant ces
propositions spécifiques à l'agriculture
biologique et espérons que la majorité
acceptera enfin d'agir vraiment contre
l'inflation je vous
remercie merci madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur temataï
leic pour le groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
nupes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers
collèguesuran d'abord vous remercier
pour ce texte qui est proposé petite
pensé pour mon camarade et et président
André chassen qui aurait dû faire cette
cette intervention qui ne peut pas être
là pour des raisons personnel qui obligé
de retourner en
famille une pensée car c'est un dossier
sur lequel le groupe communiste s'est
beaucoup battu et les mesures qui sont
proposées dans ce texte vont dans la
droite ligne de ce que le groupe
communiste avait longtemps soutenu dans
cette hémicycle alors il y a plusieurs
propositions le coefficient
multiplicateur consiste à contrôler la
marge entre le prix d'achat au
producteur et le prix vendu au
consommateur et en fait on est tous
d'accord qu'il y a des éléments exogènes
qui font qu'il y ait une
inflation mais ce qui est limité ici
dans ce texte c'est l'effet d'auben casà
cette inflation exogène et on utilise ou
du moins les monopoles utilisent
l'inflation exogène pour faire une
inflation personnelle et augment
augmenter leur marge
personnel ensuite il y a le prix
plancher donc le premier c'est pour les
consommateurs il y a le prix plancher
dans la négociation avec le producteur
et là c'est pour le producteur c'est
pour nos agriculteurs c'est pour nos
éleveurs c'est pour nos pêcheurs on a
pas beaucoup parler de ces personnes-là
ils sont concernés dans ce texte et
finalement lorsqu'on entend on a entendu
une de nos collègues dire que
l'augmentation du transport et des coûts
des matières premières à l'international
sont les raisons de cette inflation
quelle est la raison pour laquelle ça
doit être les producteurs qui doivent
payer l'inflation exogène pourquoi
est-ce que quand il y a une inflation
exogène ça doit être l'agriculteur qui
doit diminuer ses marges et des fois
vendre la perte avec une marge arrière
au distributeur et aux multinationales
et la multinationale maintient ses
surmarges et donc donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle ce prix
plancher est
important pour une sorte de de de revenu
minimum pour nos producteurs ensuite on
a entendu la ministre parler de la loi
du
marché selon
laquelle il ne faut pas qu'il ait
d'intervention de l'État la loi du
marché madame la ministre je vous la
présente en Polynésie on a un groupe qui
est détenu qui qui possède 4 80 % de la
distribution en
Polynésie ce groupe aujourd'hui se
développe dans l'agriculture ce qui fait
qu'il deviennent majoritaire dans
l'agriculture et il se développe dans le
transport ce qui fait que la loi du
marché aujourd'hui on a un distributeur
qui qui possède 80 % des hypermarchés on
a un distributeur qui a le monopole dans
l'agriculture et on a un distributeur
qui a le monopole dans le transport
c'est soit la loi du marché la loi du
marché que vous défendez c'est que le
distributeur il devient oligopole dans
la production dans la vente et dans le
transport est-ce que c'est ça le contrat
social la loi du marché c'est la loi du
plus fort et c'est pas ça le contrat
social ou du moins c'est pas ça que j'ai
compris dans le modèle politique que
vous soutenez enfin il y a quelque chose
qui a été dit c'est que le
protectionnisme peut augmenter
l'ortation ce qui a été dit par madame
la ministre je vais vous donner un
exemple pour la Polynésie en PO poésie
on est encore on n'est pas indépendant
hein donc on est encore sous la
Constitution en Polynésie toute
prodution locale madame la ministre le
gouvernement polynésien a décidé
d'interdire l'importation des types de
produits qui sont produit dans notre
pays c'est-à-dire exemple simple en
Polynésie on interdit l'importation de
tomates toutes les tomates sont
produites en Polynésie et il est
interdit d'importer des tomates à
l'extérieur donc c'est fat de dire que
le protectionnisme et l'aide dans la
production locale peut augmenter
l'importation en fait l'importation ce
sont les distributeurs qui le font parce
que les distributeurs tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est acheter le produit le
moins cher
possible et donc quand on ne soutient
pas les producteurs de toute façon si on
veut une agriculture bio si on veut des
produits de bonne qualité ça va coûter
cher ça va coûter cher c'est obligatoire
mais pourquoi est-ce que ce sont les
producteurs qui doivent diminuer leurs
recettes plutôt que les grands
distributeurs et c'est
l'objectif de cette PPL que nous allons
soutenir et enfin il y a un modèle de
société qu'il faut repenser il faut
développer l'agriculture vivrière il
faut développer la permaculture il faut
développer les marchés et arrêter de
soutenir les oligopoles et les monopoles
partout dans notre pays parce qu'on le
sait certains TPE et PME les petits
Carrefour dans les petits villages et
détenu également par les monopoles merci
monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
Lenormand pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre M et
territoire merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues les Français
qu'il soit dans l'Hexagone ou dans les
outremers ont vu les prix alimentaires
flambber en rayant de près de 18 à 22 %
en 2 ans et ce n'est malheureusement pas
sans doute près de s'arrêter les
industriels continuent des hausses
tarifaires importantes dans le cadre des
négociations commerciales ce sont ces
négociations qui déterm le prix pour
l'année à venir et avec les demandes
d'augmentation des prix c'est la
promesse de jour meilleurs qui
s'éloigne pour nos concitoyens c'est un
nouveau coup porté au pouvoir d'achat
qui se profile les difficultés
quotidiennes risque de se péréniser avec
des cadis moins remplis le relenancement
à certains produits et voir aussi des
repas sautés d'où la nécessité d'une
réponse forte des pouvoirs publics qui
se fait de plus en plus pressante nous
ne pouvons nous résigner à ce que
certains de nos concitoyens aent fa
aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'est pas à
la hauteur les mesures prises permettent
à peine d'infléchir la courbe de
l'inflation prenez le trimestre
anti-inflation son impact sur les prix
est résiduels comme le relève l'UFC Que
Choisir et la qualité des produits
choisis est
criticquable quant à la décision
d'avancer la date des négociations
commerciales elle risque pour avoir
comme seule conséquence une hausse
prématurée des prix de l'alimentaire
bref il faut trouver de nouveaux levier
pour inciter à la baisse des prix la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui de nos collègues et les
filles a le mérite de mettre cette
question sur la table elle part d'un
constat simple l'infion des matières
premières ne suffit plus à expliquer la
hausse des prix dans les supermarchés
selon les deux dernières notes de
conjoncture de l'INC de Mars et de juin
2023 l'augmentation des marges des
entreprises participe aussi à cette
dynamique dans sa version initiale le
texte proposait de mettre en place un
système d'encadrement des marges des
industries agroalimentaires et de la
distribution via la mise en place d'un
coefficient
multiplicateur nous avons fait part au
stade de la Commission de nos critiques
le système proposé était trop rigide et
sans doute peu opérationnel vous fixiez
sans distingo de filière ni de taille
d'entreprise un coefficient
multiplicateur unique sans tenir compte
aussi des coûts propres à chaque
entreprise et ce coefficient était
immuable puisqueinscrit dans la loi vous
avez proposer de réécrire une partie de
votre proposition les modifications
proposées visaient à tempérer votre
dispositif je rappelle les petites et
moyennes entreprises devraient être
exclus de l'encadrement au motif suivant
elles ne font pas de marge excessive et
elles n'ont pas les moyens humains et
financiers de rendre compte en continu
de l'évolution des dites marches le
coefficient multiplicateur lui devrait
gagner en souplesse il aurait été
renvoyé à un décret et fixé à un niveau
inférieur à la moyenne des taux de marge
brut des 10 dernières années ces
réécruur apportai de la modération mais
sans forcément satisfaire complètement
notre groupe la philosophie du texte
serait resté celle de la mise en place
d'un contrôle des prix en conséquence
potentiellement grave dans une économie
internationalisée nous le savons la
perte de compétivité de compétitivité
pardon de nos entreprises face à la
concurrence mondiale se se de souvent
par des pertes d'emploi local nous
proposons pour notre part une solution
plus consensuelle la mise en place
d'accord de modération des marges entre
les industriels et la grande
distribution nul doute que cette mesure
pourrait trouver un écho au sein de la
majorité puisque c'était l'une des
mesures mise sur la table par le
Président de la République et jamais
concrétisé au-delà de ça nous rappelons
que dans une économie de marché
l'industrie l'instrument principal pour
corriger la marge et l'impôt sur les
bénéfices des entreprises et cette
majorité n'a eu de cesse de le baisser
depuis qu'elle est arrivée aux
responsabilités s'agissant enfin de la
mise en place d'un prix plancher pour
les produits agricoles c'est une
alternative à étudier d'autant qu'on
sait que la non négociabilité des
matières premières agricoles peine à
s'appliquer dans les contrats cela étant
dit parlant du texte en l'état et tel
qu'il a été adopté en commission ce sera
rapide puisqu'il a malheureusement c'est
réduit à pot de chagrin il comprend
désormais une disposition unique unique
réécrite par les collègues républicains
et de la majorité l'Observatoire de la
formation des prix et des marges sera
chargé d'analyser les marges réalisées
dans chaque secteur tout au long de la
chaîne d'approvisionnement et
d'identifier les éventuelles pratriques
contraires aux objectifs de la loi
notons que
si n'est pas le caractère régulier des
contrôles cet article n'apporte pas de
vraie mission nouvelle à l'observatoire
qui est déjà chargé d'étudier la
répartition de la valeur ajoutée au vu
des modifications subies par la
proposition de loi en commission et
sachant qu'elle pourrait encore évoluer
nous nous réservons à l'issue des débats
pour nous positionner je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Alexis iszar pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance allez
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le président de
commission monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues avant de présenter la
position du groupe Renaissance sur ce
texte j'aimerais retracer en quelques
mots son
parcours dans sa version originale qui a
d'abord été déposée en octobre travaillé
par Monsieur bonpard et ses collègues de
la France insoumise elle contenait
quatre articles qui visaient à encadrer
les marches des distributeurs des
industriels à supprimer le dispositif de
S p + 10 c'en est suivi une série
d'auditions où l'ensemble des acteurs
ont été formels un tel texte limitera
les capacités de développement de nos
entreprises leurs possibilités
d'embauche ou encore d'investissement
dans la transition
écologique mais ne sera d'aucun bénéfice
pour le consommateur final au contraire
celui-ci risquera plutôt de se voir
priver de certains produits en rayon que
de voir son panier moyen diminé face à
ses retours le rapporteur s'est retrouvé
bien embêté comment maintenir un texte
que personne ne veut et dont l'utilité
est largement remise en question et bien
c'est simple dans la nuit du 21 au 22
novembre 2023 date de l'examen en
commission monsieur bonpard a
intégralement réécrit son texte par voie
d'amendement ne laissant que quelques
heures nocturnes au commissaires pour
prendre connaissance des évolutions et
lui-même a d'ailleurs été en peine de
nous expliquer ses modifications sur son
texte au final une seconde version
bancale absolument pas à la hauteur des
enjeux sur lesquels je
reviendrai de la version originale que
tout le monde rejetait il ne reste
aujourd'hui qu'une troisième version
comprenant un article unique
intégralement réécrit par un amendement
de Monsieur
div le dispositif introduit en
commission renforce l'émission de
l'Observatoire de la formation des prix
et des marges des produits alimentaires
si ces nouvelles prérogatives peuvent
encore être précisé le dispositif n
reste pour autant pas moins intéressant
j'aiévoqué il y a quelques instants les
auditions qui se sont tenues entre la
première et la deè version du texte
celles-ci ont toutes mis en avant
l'inefficacité de l'encadrement des
marches tel que vous le proposez mais
elles ont en revanche souligner
l'importance d'introduire plus de
transparence à la fois du côté des
distributeurs et des industriels il me
paraît en effet essentiel d'accroître la
transparence tant pour éviter l'écueil
des marges excessives que pour informer
nos concitoyens je vous proposerai ainsi
dans quelques minutes plusieurs
amendements qui viseront à renforcer
encore les dispositions introduites en
commission notamment rendeau obligatoire
et non plus facultatif la publication
des rapports de cet observatoire des
prix et des marges ou encore en
précisant la fréquence de publication de
ce rapport il me paraît en effet
essentiel chers collègues que notre
assemblée se saisisse du sujet de la
transparence des marges et je me réouis
ainsi que cette proposition de loi
intégralement réécrite nous donne au
moins la possibilité de débattre d'un
sujet autour duquel les attentes sont
nombreuses je saiterai par ailleurs
insister sur le fait que le parcours de
cette proposition de loi ne doit pas
nous faire oublier qu'il y a des un
enjeu essentiel le pouvoir d'achat de
nos
concitoyens j'en une porte ouverte en
disant que pour beaucoup de Français et
de français il est devenu difficile de
remplir son panier de course ou de se
loger nous connaissons la raison de cela
une inflation forte du notamment un
contexte géopolitique instable et une
hausse des coûs des matières premières
sur un fond de crise
écologique pourtant j'aimerais poser une
question à Monsieur bonpard et à mes
collègues de la France insoumise qui
sont si qui sont si verbal aujourd'hui
vous qui vous présentez comme les
chevaliers blanc pouir vous qui vous
présentez comme les chevaliers blancs du
pouvoir d'achat où étiez-vous où
étiez-vous quand nous avons voté le
bouclier tarifaire où étiez-vous qu nous
avons voté les aides exceptionnelles de
rentré où étiez-vous pour le vote des
revalorisation des minimas sociaux et
des bourses étudiantes vous écumez les
plateaux de télévision enregistrez des
capsules pour vos réseaux sociaux mais
quand vient le moment d'approuver des
mesures concrètes pour les français où
êtes-vous cette journée ustre encore
dans lequel vous vous enfoncez toujours
plus résoudre la crise du logement chez
les hones rouvenir les accueils dans les
services publics indexer les salaires
sur l'inflation encadrer les marges
autant de textes au titre racoleur mais
aux propositions creuses et inapplica
mes chers collègues ce ne sont pas des
solutions que vous cherchez ce sont des
coupables vous instrumentalisez les
difficultés des Français pour les
imputer à notre majorité au gouvernement
ou encore comme vous l'avez fait tout à
l'heure au président de la République
pour autant vous savez pertinemment que
vos solution sont dogmatiques qu'elle ne
fonctionne pas mais au final qu'importe
puisque vous aurez vos capsules vidéo
pour ma part et je conclurai là-dessus
je suis fier d'appartenir à la majorité
qui agit depuis des mois pour soulager
le pouvoir d'achat des Français que cela
soit en avançant les négociations
commerciales en revalorisant certaines
aides ou plus efficacement encore en
faisant en sorte que le travail pai sans
dogmatisme avec du pragmatisme et
efficacité alors vous l'aurez compris le
groupe Renaissance sera en faveur d'un
texte qui assure une nécessaire
transparence sur les marges en
renforçant les prérogatives de
l'Observatoire des prises et des marges
mais jamais en faveur d'un texte qui
casse le développement de nos
entreprises sans soutenir les Françaises
ni même les Français
merci merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Julien
di pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicain madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur président chers
collègues en mars 2023 au plus fort de
la crise les prix de l'alimentation ont
connu une hausse de 15,9 % par rapport à
l'année précédente en cause la guerre en
Ukraine la reprise économique
post-pandémie et les alléas climatiques
qui ont fait flamber les prix des
matières premières et de l'énergie au
bout de cette chaîne complexe ce sont
bien les Français qui se retrouvent à
régler l'addition salée à la caisse
l'esprit initial du texte que vous nous
présentez à nouveau ce matin monsieur le
rapporteur était de s'attaquer aux
profiteurs de crise en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je l'ai décelé en
commission ceux qui ont pu dans le cadre
de l'inflation faire des marges
importantes au cours de ces dernières
années dans le contexte que je viens de
mentionner l'objectif que nous
partageons tous il me semble
c'est-à-dire la défense du pouvoir
d'achat de nos concitoyens et que nous
retrouvons par le biais de ce texte est
à saluer mais il convient d'y apporter
des nuances en effet la plus grande
erreur que nous ferions serait de céder
à la tentation de la caricature le tissu
entrepreneurial de notre économie ne se
réduit pas à une poignée d'acteurs
cherchant uniquement et toujours attirer
avantage de la situation au détriment
des citoyens il est vrai des effets
d'obèes peuvent surgir ici et là et on
les connaît mais ces exemples sont
marginaux au moment où nous nous
efforçons d'attirer des investisseurs de
prévenir les délocalisations et de
promouvoir le dynamisme du tissu local
il ne faut pas fragiliser l'économie
française à l'inverse bon nombre
d'entreprises ancrées sur notre sol
contribu à la création d'emploi et
constitue une ligne de défense contre la
précarité comme je l'ai fait en
commission je veux prendre exemple de ma
circonscription l'usine LU montdelaise
du village de juusy ce site de
production agroalimentaire installé
depuis un siècle dans l'INE a été touché
par un incendie à l'automne 2020 ce qui
engendrait la destruction de 50 % de
l'outil de production des bâtiments et
Infiné du chômage partiel le siège de
mondelaise qui se trouve à 7000 km de là
à Chicago vue de Chicago jusci ce n'est
qu'un point un pion sur une carte de
l'Europe et si nous n'avions pas montré
que l'investissement en France était
bénéfique que les retours sur
investissement étaient réels qu'il y
avait une main d'œuvre de qualité des
gens qualifiés qui aiment leur
territoire et leur métier ce n'est pas
en France que le groupe aurait réinvesti
50 millions d'euros et ainsi maintenu
ses centaines d'emplois donc certes la
transparence sur les marges nécessaires
contraindre les groupes qui ne publb pas
annuellement leur compte à le faire les
tout autant forcer une imitation à tout
prix en revanche de forc pardon une
limitation à tout prix en revanche
envoie un signal négatif de l'économie
française aux investisseurs ainsi au
lieu d'imposer une régulation rigide des
marges bénéficiaires des industries
agroalimentaires nous prenons une
approche fondée sur la transparence une
surveillance renforcée et la stimulation
de la concurrence une méthode à la fois
plus adaptée plus efficace favorisant
une compétition saine la sauvegarde des
des petits acteurs les bénéfices pour
les consommateurs et la prévention des
pratiques abusive concernant le débat du
prix planché vous allez tenter monsieur
le rapporteur par voix d'amendement de
rétablir une partie de l'article 1 dans
un état d'esprit d'ouverture et
constructif j'ai souhaité sous-amender
votre amendement à plusieurs
reprises notamment sur la question des
indicateurs de prix qui on le sait sont
le cœur des négociations commerciales
mais nous ne leurons pas le débat sur le
partage de la valeur la préservation du
revenu d'agriculteur seule source de son
émancipation est garantie à la
transmission installation ne sera
possible qu'au prix d'une ultime réforme
des négociations commerciales pour
laquelle nous en jooignons le
gouvernement à s'engager en 2024 car
l'inaction du gouvernement sur ce sujet
engendrerait une pluie de fauses
solutions tout aussi nocives les unes
que les autres pour le monde agricole
chasser les marges multiplier les
jachers valider la stratégie ferme tout
forc ferme les yeux sur l'accord
Mercosur qui se trame en coulisse sortir
de l'Europe et tuer la pâqu pour
certains et n'entraînerit ainsi les
agriculteurs français que dans une
papérisation massive pour conclure sur
votre PPL l'adoption de celle-ci a mandé
au commission et conférent à
l'Observatoire de la formation des prix
des marques un roge central dans la
surveillance du marché agroalimentaire
constitue une étape significative vers
un marché plus équitable et transparent
le groupe LR maintiendra la position qui
était la sienne en commission à
condition que les débats que nous allons
voir ne s'écartte pas de notre esprit
initial nous sommes résolus à faire
progresser les mesures qui renforcent
notre économie et préservve l'intérêt de
nos concitoyens je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député la discussion
générale est close avant de donner la
parole à Monsieur le rapporteur et
monsieur le Président je vous informe
que sur le vote de l'amendement numéro 1
et l'amendement numéro 12 je suis saisie
par le groupe la France insoumise
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale d'une demande de scrutin public
les scrutins sont annoncés dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais de dire quelques mots de
réaction sur les les interventions qui
ont qui ont eu lieu d'abord madame la
ministre vous nous avez invité à
légiférer sérieusement et vous avez
raison et moi je vous invite à lire
sérieusement et à lire attentivement les
propositions que nous faisons ainsi dans
votre argumentation vous avez évoqué la
question des petites et moyennes
entreprises ou la question des
entreprises de distribution de petite
taille madame la ministre je vous
informe que dans la proposition que nous
faisons les entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire dont le chiffre
d'affaires est inférieur à 350 millions
sont exclus de la mise en place de ce
dispositif comme les entreprises de
distribution qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires inférieur à 2 millions auou
moins de 10 salariés
deuxièmement deuxièmement madame la
ministre deuxièmement madame la ministre
vous nous avez reproché de proposer
cette proposition de loi sans nous être
intéressé par exemple à son
éventuel problème de constitutionnalité
là aussi madame la ministre vous dites
quelque chose de totalement inexact
puisque précisément si nous proposons de
mettre en place à la fois un dispositif
qui rentre en vigueur en 2024 et ensuite
un dispositif qui pourrait s'activer
dans des dispositions économiques
particulières c'est justement pour qu'il
puisse être constitutionnel comme il est
permis de bloquer les prix dans des
situations économiques exceptionnelles
et il est possible d'avoir des
dispositifs d'encadrement des marges
dans des situations économiques
exceptionnel troisièmement vous avez
contesté les chiffres qui sont dans
notre proposition de loi Madame le
Ministre j'ai très mauvaise nouvelle
pour vous ces chiffres sont les chiffres
de l'INC et les coefficients
multiplicateurs qui sont proposés
reviennent à prendre la marge moyenne
qui a été réalisée selon l'INC par les
entreprises sur les 10 dernières
années vous avez et je ne doute pas que
le président de la Commission fera la
même chose vous avez voulu agiter le
spectre de la caricature en faisait
référence à des dispositifs qui
existeraient dans tel ou tel pays
peut-être ne savez-vous pas qu'il existe
au Canada un dispositif qui permet
d'avoir des prix planchés pour les
matières agricoles peut-être ne
savez-vous pas qu'il existe et qu'il a
existé en Nouvelle-Calédonie des
dispositifs d'encadrement des marges
peut-être ne savez-vous pas que
vous-même cette minorité présidentielle
dans le dernier projet de loi de finance
de la sécurité sociale avait encadré des
possibilités d'encadrement des marches
sur des dispositifs médicau
et puisque vous avez agité le spectre du
communisme j'ai une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour vous monsieur le
rapporteur général en 2011 Monsieur
estri déposé une proposition de loi pour
encadrer les marches de la distribution
et elles étai et cette proposition de
loi é éta signée par Monsieur Vigier qui
est aujourd'hui ministre dans votre
gouvernement madame Grégoire attention
vous siégez avec un
communiste dans une majorité qui a dans
le projet de loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale l'année dernière mis en
place des dispositifs d'encadrement des
marges donc soyez un petit peu cohérent
je pense que ça ferait du bien à la
discussion enfin je voudrais dire à
monsieur iszar qui est intervenu tout à
l'heure je ne sais pas si lui a eu pour
objectif de faire sa propre capsule
vidéo mais finalement son intervention
était assez
significative de votre manière de
penser effectivement dans les auditions
les représentants de la grose
distribution se sont opposés à l'idée
que nous allions encadrer les marches de
la grande distribution effectivement
dans les auditions les représentants de
l'industrie agroalimentaire se sont
opposés au fait qu'on allait encadrer
les marches de l'industrie
agroalimentaire mais chers collègues les
représentants de l'industrie
agroalimentaire le représentant de la
distribution ce n'est pas le peuple
français et votre responsabilité c'est
d'agir pour le peuple français pas
d'agir pour défendre les intérêts de
certains acteurs économiques et vous
n'avez pas oublié et si vous l'avez
oublié je vous le rappelle et je
m'arrêterai là-dessus qu'ier quatre
associations de consommateurs les quatre
associations de consommateurs
principales de ce pays vous ont demandé
d'agir enfin pour avoir plus de
transparence et pour faire en sorte de
lutter contre les marges excessives donc
plutôt que la caricature non mais
monsieur casbaran pour la transparence
et pour faire en sorte d'agir enfin
contre les marges excessives donc madame
la ministre vous êtes opposé notre
proposition de loi je l'entends très
bien j'attends de savoir qu'est-ce que
vous proposez comme proposition
alternative pour faire enfin votre
travail merci Monsieur le le
rapporteur je vous informe que sur le
vote des sous-amendements 53 est
identique je suis saisi par le groupe
renaissance d'une demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
monsieur le Président casbarian vous
avez la parole et je suis sûre que
l'attention va être comment tout le
monde va être très attentif et je
n'aurai pas demander le silence je
l'espère évidemment madame la présidente
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues alors nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour examiner
une PPL qui est inspirée par
probablement les meilleurs économistes
de la faculté de
Caracas et effectivement au même titre
que vous assumez votre marxisme
pardonnez-moi d'assumer mon libéralisme
notre libéralisme sur un certain nombre
de
sujets c'est pas un gros mot c'est pas
un gros mot c'est une bataille d'idée
qui est for intéressante et que nous
avons pu avoir en commission et que nous
avons
aujourd'hui comme nous l'avons vu en
commission oui votre proposition propose
un système de blocage des prix et de
blocage des marges c'est le retour des
prix administrés du contrôle des marges
de l'étatisation de l'économie de
l'économie administrée c'est ça le cœur
de votre texte et c'est ce que vous avez
toujours défendu en toute cohérence bon
nous ce que nous disons c'est qu'au-delà
des aspects idéologiques que nous
assumons il n'existe aucune
preuve de fonctionnement des blocages de
prix et des marges dans notre histoire
économique française mais même mondiale
je pourrais vous citer en 301 à Rome le
blocage des prix de 1000 produits
alimentaires qui a conduit à des pénurie
et du troc je pourrais vous citer la
décision des députés de la Convention en
1793 qui vote la loi du maximum général
regardez monsieur léom applaudit donc il
souscrit il souscrit du maximum G qui
bloque pris pour faire la guerre aux
accapareurs voilà l'effet a été à peu
près nul les greniers se sont vidés les
magasins se sont vidés les paysans ont
caché leur récolte et comme ça marchait
pas les députés de l'époque ont décidé
de mettre la peine de mort et la
guillotine à ceux qui ne jouaient pas le
jeu grande efficacité de ces mesures de
contrôle de prix et des mararches déjà
imaginé à l'époque chers collègues seul
s'il vous plaît seul le président la
parole et ça vient de tous les bancs
Paris
1974 un plan qui est cher à Grégoire de
fourn
le plan Fourcade sur le refroidissement
avec là encore des systèmes de blocage
de prix et des marges résultat 9 %
d'inflation chute de la production
industrielle de 19 % chômage en
augmentation si bien que un an plus tard
c'est tellement catastrophique ils sont
obligés de faire un plan de relance
parce que ça n'a pas marché j'aurais pu
vous citer parce que vous m'avez dit
tout à l'heure monsieur de fournass
qu'on il fallait aller au-delà des
exemples soviétiques et vous remarquez
que j'ai pas cité l'Union soviétique je
pourrais vous citer l'exemple du
Zimbabwe en 2007 qui bloque les prix
alimentaires pénurie en quelques mois je
pourrais vous citer l'exemple du
Cameroun 2008 blocage des prix du ciment
plus de ciment plus de construction plus
de BTP qu'est-ce qui se passe on est
obligé d'abandonner cette merveilleuse
idée du contrôle et de l'administration
des prix Argentine 2021 blocage des prix
de la viande que se passe-t-il du coup
les producteurs de viande décident
d'exporter en disant vu que je ne peux
pas vendre mes prix au bon prix dans mon
pays j'exporte et comme le gouvernement
se rend compte qu'il y a de
l'exportation et qu'il y a plus de VI
dans les supermarchés en Argentine
qu'est-ce qu'il faut ils interdisent les
exportations qu'est-ce qui se passe
ensuite et ben les producteurs mettent
n'importe quoi dans les paquets de
viande du gras des os et cetera pour se
conformer au prix qui a été fixé par le
gouvernement argentin Irlande 2022
blocage des loyers à force de bloquer
les loyer on aboutit à une situation où
il n'y a que 700 maisons en Irlande qui
peuvent être louées parce que plus
personne ne veut louer parce que les
prix ont été complètement bloqués
moralité le marché immobilier est
complètement bloqué il y a des centaines
de personnes qui font la queue on est
obligé de sélectionner les locataires au
tirage au sort tellement ça marche pas
bref vous le voyez et j'ai toujours pas
cité d'exemples soviétiqu ni vénézuélien
ni cubain le blocage des prix le blocage
des marches ça n'a jamais marché nulle
part ni dans les économies administrées
ni dans les économies de marché on peut
continuer la liste des exemples est très
nombreuse j'en viens à une réponse à
Monsieur de fournass madame la
Présidente qui nous dit vous vous notez
notre convergence de vue avec LFI mais
bien évidemment vous convergez puisque
vous allez voter le blocage des prix et
des marges avec eux donc ne vous cachez
pas vous convergez avec la France
insoumise sur ces vieux
mécanismes et votre président de parti
monsieur Bardella était cette semaine
l'invité d'achc où il a dit cette phrase
extraordinaire nous instaurerons un
rapport de confiance avec les ménages et
les entreprises mais monsieur Bardella a
oublié de dire ce que vous êtes en train
de voter cette semaine avec la France
insoumise il a oublié de rappeler que
vous avez voté le blocage des prix
alimentaires il y a quelques mois en
avril il a oublié de dire que vous aviez
défendu le blocage des prix de
l'électricité en octobre il a oublié de
dire que vous étiez contre la réforme du
RSA en novembre il a oublié de dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez voter main
dans la main une proposition de blocage
des prix et des marges alors ne vous
cachez pas je le vois tous les jours
quand je regarde en commission des
affaires économiques sur le plan
économique le rassemblement national
vote exactement les mêmes proposition
que la gauche de la gauche de
l'hémicycle vous convergez assumez-le je
dirais madame la présidente que je suis
ravi qu'on ait cette discussion mais que
effectivement vous le verrez tout au
long de la discussion ni les arguments
théoriques ni la pratique ni la pratique
depuis des centaines d'années ne permet
d'attester que le blocage des prix et
des marches fonctionne rien monsieur le
rapporteur a fait parler un peu vite je
trouve les organisations de
consommateurs qu'on soit d'accord sur la
transparence bien évidemment qu'on est
d'accord pour la transparence il faut
faire la lumière sur les prix et les
marges et essayer de la décomposer c'est
d'ailleurs le rôle de l'Observatoire des
prix et des marges qu'on essaie de
renforcer mais personne ne vous a dit
monsieur bonpard que il était favorable
au blocage des prix et des marges aucune
organisation agricole ne réclame le prix
le blocage des prix et des marges aucune
organisation industrielle ne réclame le
blocage des prix et des marges aucune
organisation de consommateur réclame le
blocage des prix et des mararges
personne ne le réclame si ce n'est votre
idéologie on va avoir ce beau débat
ensemble maintenant je vous remercie et
place au
débat merci monsieur le
président je n'ai pas d'autre demande
d'explication sur la proposition de loi
je vais donc la mettre au
voix avec un scrutin public j'invite
chacun à regagner sa place le scrutin
est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos votons 330 exprimé 330 majorité 166
pour 162 contre 168 oui l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas
adopté